bien mes chers amis les chairs et
minutes il de vous dire l'émotion qui
est la mienne qui est une émotion
partagée en ce jour historique de
refondation de la famille politique
vive les républicains je prends je
prends la parole quelques semaines après
une victoire électorale et sans
précédent à l'occasion des élections
départementales
cette victoire c'est d'abord la victoire
de nos idées de nos principes de nos
valeurs le fait de mettre à égalité les
droits et les devoirs
le fait d'avoir affirmé pendant toute
cette campagne électorale que celui qui
reçoit et qui a le droit de recevoir une
aide sociale de la collectivité doit en
contrepartie et a le devoir de donner du
temps à la collectivité aux personnes
âgées aux personnes handicapées c'est un
principe clair que nous avons affirmé
qui a fait notre succès mais ce succès
ce succès n'aurait rien n'était s'il n'y
avait pas eu une mobilisation sans
faille de nos fédérations sur le terrain
gelé bien vu partout à travers le
français en particulier dans mon
département de l'oise que nous avons
conquis nous militons ont été au rendez
vous ils ont été au rendez vous du début
de la reconquête
ils le seront encore comment toute cette
fin d'année avec les élections
régionales et pour la longue marche qui
va nous mener jusqu'aux présidentielles
alors évidemment il ne faudra rien
lâcher le parti est en mouvement le
parti est mobilisé et il le doit
d'ailleurs à son président nicolas
sarkozy dont l'engagement a été sans
faille pour refonder notre famille
politique
alors évidemment les mois qui sont
devant nouveau exigé
ils mobilisation sans faille je les dis
alors même que françois hollande ne va
rien lâcher
ou plutôt ou plutôt il va lâcher des
promesses il va lâcher des mensonges
comme il l'a toujours fait en se disant
comme d'ailleurs c'est dit dans un
célèbre film les bronzés
on sait jamais sur un malentendu ça peut
marcher mais nous ne le laisserons pas
faire nous ne serons pas faire
évidemment parce que c'est ce qu'attend
de nos concitoyens nos concitoyens qui
attendent l'alternance avec impatience
nos fédérations sont en marche en marche
pour la victoire la victoire des
républicains est pour la france